we are seeing Prince Harry for the first
time since last week's surprise
announcement that he and his wife Megan
Marco are stepping back from their royal
roles MTS Tire visit Buckingham Palace
with more on this story
MTS people always like to see it when
Prince Harry shows up so what's on his
schedule today good morning yeah we do
and Prince Harry is here at Buckingham
Palace making an announcement about a
major British sporting events looking
very calm very relaxed and smiling for a
man who's at the center of a major
crisis for the royal family in 2022 the
Invictus games will travel to a new
country Prince Harry is back supporting
sports and mental health causes he cares
about that it is not just about being
physically fit but more importantly
mentally strong but how much more will
be seeing of him in the future is still
unclear says the Sunday Times royal
correspondent Roy Anika his first public
appearance since dropping that bombshell
that he's effectively leaving the royal
family and what we don't know is whether
not because the last public engagement
he's going to do for a while but Harry
wasn't taking any questions on the
subject the Queen has given her staff
just days to work out what Harry and
Megan's new role as step back Royals
will look like but this might be the
first glimpse Megan in Canada where the
couple plan to split their time making a
surprise visit to a women shelter it
feels like she's already carving out
that new role in Canada while details
are being flashed out here as to what
that role is gonna look like this while
the Mail on Sunday newspaper is
preparing to defend itself against the
lawsuit filed by Megan and Harry who
accused them of publishing private
correspondence between Megan and her
father Thomas Markel with the shocking
suggestion he may testify against his
own daughter that is going to be toxic
for the royal family
Markel vs. Michael and all the details
of the family communications and
breakdown in a courtroom and is not what
the royal family wants to see now it's
still unclear when Prince Harry will
join his wife and son in
no though we do understand that he does
have some meetings scheduled here in the
UK for next week but it would appear one
of Canada's top newspapers is already
giving the royal couple the cold
shoulder by publishing an editorial
saying that they're not welcome for
quote constitutional reasons whatever
the case if it seemed the polls are on
their side with most Canadians saying
they'd be happy to have them Tony yeah
it's high up in London in tears thank
you very much including the Prime
Minister Trudeau that said that they
would be welcome but I love the reporter
and hollering and Harry Harry what do
you say about your future best way to
get somebody not to answer your question
is to shout it out as they're trying to
get away yeah they go where was that out
there I think that could do better but
for her particular family Zac know you
can do that to your daughter no I don't
either
you